la vie de malika a basculé le 2 juillet
ce jour-là sa fille maria alors âgé de 8
mois a failli se noyer dans la piscine
familiale l'enfant flottait dans une
bouée
quelques minutes avant l'accident tout
le monde nage et tout ça allait bien
d'un seul coup on trouve mari à la tête
dans l'eau et les jambes en l'air
émile mon conjoint la sortie de l'eau
mais elles étaient toutes monf démarche
ans le père de maria avait suivi une
formation de maître nageur
il a pu réanimer sa fille avant
l'arrivée des secours
aujourd'hui la petite fille se portent
bien et n'a pas de séquelles mais sa
mère a vécu un véritable traumatisme
depuis le début de l'année trente sept
personnes sont mortes noyées au québec
ces trois de plus que l'an dernier à la
même date en cette semaine nationale de
prévention de la noyade son directeur
général rappelle les règles de sécurité
de base comme le port d'une veste de
flottaison et l'importance de la
surveillance des enfants qui jouent dans
l'eau retenez l'expression que si
l'enfant n'est pas à la portée de la
main c'est parce qu'il est déjà trop
loin lorsque vous êtes près de l'eau les
gens m'ont pas crier il va pas y avoir
rappelé d'éclaboussures nécessairement
partout on va juste voir la personne qui
montent petit dessin c'est très rapide
dans vraiment là c'est une question
c'est une question de dix minutes c'est
une question de secondes
le programme nager pour survivre qui est
offert à près de quinze mille enfants
dont 250 écoles au québec gagnerait à
être étendues à tous les enfants de la
province
est ce que tu es capable de remonter à
la surface te maintenir la surface
pendant 60 secondes prendre le contrôle
de ta respiration puis repéré l'endroit
où tu pourras et accrocher un enfant sur
deux réussi ce que je viens de vous dire
à l'âge de 8 ans au québec
ok lorsque je suis dans des milieux de
défavorisation ses trois enfants sur 10
qui réussit la noyade est un drame
évitable et malika on a fait la
douloureuse expérience
honnêtement je souhaite mon expérience à
aucun parent
il faut rester vraiment vigilant ici
florence guaino radio canada montréal